MARK MIRCHANDANI: When working
with a job search service,
artificial intelligence
can improve
the experience of your
candidates and employers.
In the last set of
videos, we looked
at what the Google Cloud
Talent Solution Job Search
API offers and gave some
general tips for using it.
Now, let's write some code
and start working with the API
itself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In order to use
the API, we'll need
to go through code
using the client
libraries, REST interface,
or RPC interface.
The client libraries are the
easiest way to get started,
so we'll be using those
for any examples here.
But the structure
is still the same
if you want to use the
REST or RPC interfaces.
We'll be using version three
of the API for all of our code.
Don't forget to check the
documentation for the latest
updates.
First thing's first, we'll
need a Google Cloud Platform
project with billing
enabled to work from.
If you're not sure
how to do this,
I'd recommend checking out the
links in the description first,
then coming back to
this video when you've
got the GCP basics set up.
With the GCP project,
we can open up
the navigation in the
top left, and look
for Talent Solution,
which will be
under Artificial Intelligence.
When we click on
Overview, we should
get redirected to
a screen that asks
us to enable the API since this
might be a new GCP project.
Easily enough, we can just
click that Enable button
to turn on the API for
the current project.
This may take a few minutes,
but once it's enabled,
anything we do in the context
of this project can use the API.
Keep in mind that if you
want to use multiple projects
with the API, you'll need to
enable it for each project.
After that's done, we'll head
back to the Overview page
and have a new screen show up--
a data-logging
requirement notification.
This is really just making sure
you know that the Job Search
API is powered by a
machine-learning model that
needs data.
As part of the
integration, we'll
actually be able
to send over events
from users who are searching
to further train those models.
When this is implemented
through code,
you can specify which pieces
of information get sent over.
We'll dive deeper into
what those events are
and how to send them later,
but the pre-trained models
will work just fine for now.
So we'll go ahead and
enable Data Logging
and click on Service
Account Connections.
See, when making
API requests, you'll
need to make them on behalf
of an actual authenticated
account.
Google Cloud Platform's
best practices
recommend setting up a
service account for this.
Once again, there's a link
in the description for more
about service accounts, but
think of them as an easy way
to set up authenticated users
who have limited permissions
so you can build an
independent and secure system.
We'll need a service account
to use the Job Search API,
so let's create one and give
it read-write permissions using
Job Editor under the Cloud
Talent Solution section.
It's also possible to
set up a service account
with just Job Viewer so it would
only have read-only access.
One more note to be
aware of-- especially
if you're importing
a lot of jobs at once
or dealing with a high
volume of search requests,
you should be aware of quotas.
You can see your quotas on
the admin page and request
increases if needed.
If you see an error message
related to quota or to jobs
still being indexed,
the quota page
may help to see what's going on.
Check out the quota page
in the ever-growing link
farm down below to see
what the default quotas are
and how to raise them.
OK.
That's enough set up for now.
We've got everything we
actually need to run some code,
so let's do it.
We'll use the Client
Libraries in Python,
but you can check the
docs for code samples
in your preferred language.
We'll also use the
convenient Cloud Shell
that you can access
through the console.
If you're doing this from
your own environment,
make sure to get the Google
Cloud SDK and the client
libraries installed.
To run the code
using the libraries,
you just need to make sure
some environment variables are
set up--
one for the project, and one
for the path to your service
account's key file.
Let's start off with
something simple--
just listening all the
companies that we have.
This is our code on the top and
the Cloud Shell on the bottom.
You can see that we
set up the project
ID using the
environment variable,
and in the list
companies function,
we'll just list the companies
by passing the project ID.
Then, we'll loop to the
results and print them all out.
Of course, there's no
companies because we
haven't created any yet.
So let's take a look at how
to create a basic company.
This function will create
a company that's passed in.
The request is pretty
similar to the last one,
but we're calling create
with some additional fields.
We'll pass in a
very basic company
with only the required fields--
display name and external ID.
When we run this, we'll see
that the company was created,
and it has a name, which
is a unique identifier used
in the API.
Now, when we list
our companies, we'll
see the new one we created,
as well as its name.
See, the name is the
unique identifier
generated by the Job Search
API, while the external ID is
the identifier you provide
from your own job system.
Anytime you refer to an
object through the API,
you'll need to use the name.
We'll talk about that
in the next video
when we dive more into
working with companies.
In the meantime, you can always
check out the documentation
for more info.
Thanks for watching,
and remember,
when looking for talent, it's OK
to keep your head in the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]